y
[Música]
de todos y todas
y
estos ataúdes están siendo enterrados en
una fosa común en chernigov una ciudad
del norte de ucrania en esta localidad
que lleva un mes bajo el bombardero ruso
700 personas han muerto según las
autoridades locales pero al igual que en
el resto del país el número exacto de
muertes causados por la guerra sigue
siendo difícil de evaluar para tratar de
documentar el costo humano del conflicto
organizaciones internacionales e
investigadores en línea utilizan
imágenes satelitales y vídeos publicados
en las redes sociales esto permite por
ejemplo ver más cerca los cementerios
que se han hecho como este center for
information resilientes tomó imágenes de
un bosque cerca de cher vigo ven mccann
supervisó esta investigación
en
la imagen que inició la investigación
fue publicada por red usa un sitio web
de noticias independientes en ruso
[Música]
empezamos a buscar una zona similar a la
que se puede ver en esta foto
se puede ver un bosque y al fondo un
gran cementerio que ha estado ahí
durante un tiempo por lo que podemos
limitar nuestra búsqueda
empezamos a utilizar las imágenes
satelitales que se han recopilado es el
comienzo del conflicto
y luego analizamos las imágenes
disponibles en las redes sociales esto
consiste en ver si coinciden los árboles
las lápidas las características de la
carretera o incluso los pecados de las
estructuras del fondo fuera del
cementerio el seguir buscando
encontramos más imágenes que mostraban a
que escala habían sido enterrados los
civiles en el cementerio
pudimos identificar
350 tumbas individuales
y los investigadores pueden demostrar
con imágenes satelitales que estas
tumbas eran nuevas ya que el terreno fue
despejado tras el inicio de la ofensiva
rusa sin embargo reconocen que su
trabajo no les permite conocer los
detalles de lo ocurrido
sabemos que los rusos compartieron
ampliamente charlie cox y devin harris
sabemos que ha habido víctimas civiles
como resultado del bombardeo de la
ciudad
[Música]
presen posible afirmaron con certeza que
las 350 tumbas son resultado directo de
la invasión rusa
el reto ahora es cotejar nuestras
investigaciones con los testimonios de
las personas que vivieron lo que duró de
la violencia
y
las ong como el center for information
resilience esperan que su trabajo de
investigación pueda utilizarse algún día
en los tribunales junto con otras
informaciones
son las 4 de la mañana y
nos rechazaron en belarús está lloviendo
mucho todas nuestras pertenencias están
mojados y estas familias del kurdistán
iraquí intentó entrar en polonia de
belarús a mediados de abril en 2021
decenas de miles de inmigrantes de
oriente medio y áfrica central tomaron
esta nueva ruta migratoria con la
esperanza de llegar a la unión europea
la mayoría de ellos fueron rechazados
por polonia durante el invierno las
llamadas de auxilio de los migrantes
bloqueados en esta frontera disminuyeron
sin embargo están empezando a aumentar
de nuevo según nuestra observadora del
colectivo de asociaciones grupo a
granizar
en una semana a finales de abril tuvimos
unas 150 personas que nos pidieron ayuda
es el número promedio de personas que
cruzan la frontera y por supuesto hay
muchos más que no tienen ayuda tenemos
por desgracia muchas familias con niños
muchas personas con diferentes
discapacidades personas mayores personas
con discapacidades mentales también
aquí estamos lo juro las condiciones son
muy malas nadie durmió anoche debido a
la lluvia
y la gran mayoría de estas personas han
sido rechazadas repetidamente por los
guardias fronterizos polacos después los
soldados o guardias belarusos los
obligan repetidamente a cruzar de nuevo
la frontera
el pasado mes de noviembre belarús
convirtió un antiguo almacén en un
refugio para cientos de migrantes
bloqueados en la frontera muchos fueron
devueltos a sus países según nuestro
observador a las últimas personas que se
encontraban en el almacén incluidas
familias y personas enfermas y
discapacitadas
fueron desalojadas en marzo ahora
intentan volver a cruzar la frontera con
otros grupos que escaparon a la
deportación
también sabemos que varias personas
pasaron el invierno en migrón 2 en
belarús
y ahora que hace un poco más de calor
están intentando cruzar de nuevo
también creo que algunas personas
intentan cruzar ahora porque polo me
está construyendo un muro les
todos
berlin
obviamente el muro no es un obstáculo
tan grande en realidad es solo una
barrera metálica pero una vez que este
muro esté equipado como muchas fronteras
europeas con todas las herramientas
técnicas para vigilarlos creo que será
mucho más difícil de cruzar tu según los
guardias fronterizos polacos sólo en
abril se registraron casi 1000 intentos
de cruzar ilegalmente la frontera con
belarús a modo de comparación en octubre
de 2021 plena crisis migratoria se
registraron casi 17.000 intentos
esto es todos los observadores de esta
semana le damos las gracias a vélez para
ti cejil nuestra locación para esta
grabación y les recordamos también que
si quieren volver a ver este vídeo lo
único que tienen que hacer es entrar a
nuestra página web por otro lado si
quieren ponerse en contacto con nosotros
tomen nota de los datos que aparecen en
pantalla sigan con más información en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom hasta
pronto